Mega Pock.
Der Feuer ist wieder am Start.
Oh nein.
Ne, ne, ne. Heute kein Rust.
Heute müsst ihr mir mal helfen,
was zu schreiben.
Ich krieg's nicht auf die Reihe.
Ich hab doch morgen
nochmal als Jahresabschluss
quasi. Ich hab ja eigentlich schon Urlaub.
So bis
Januar. Aber wir haben
morgen noch einen zweitägigen
Teambuilding-Workshop.
Nicht in Frankfurt,
sondern extern irgendwo
im Hotel. Glücklicherweise nicht ganz so weit
weg. Also ich komm da relativ gut
hin und dann wieder weg. Aber
zumindest. Ich hab mir
die letzten paar Wochen
über immer mal
ein paar Sachen aufgeschrieben,
was ich denke, was sinnvoll ist,
bei diesem Teambuilding anzusprechen. Aber
ich bin einfach viel zu
blöd, das irgendwie so
verständlich
zu schreiben, dass man damit
was anfangen kann.
Deswegen hab ich mir gedacht, ich mach das mit dem
Chat zusammen. Was soll da schon schief gehen?
Chatge ist ja
bekanntermaßen absolut sick
im Six-Hat-Mode. Steinharder
lang, ich füll den Zap.
Was muss Community machen? Ich erzähl's gleich nochmal.
Wenn noch mehr Community-ge
am Start ist. In der Zwischenzeit
starte ich mal
meine VM
und upgrade
mal die Packages.
Oh.
Vor allem mal Workstation.
17.5 ist raus.
Ist das nicht schon eine ganze Weile?
17.5?
Das ist doch schon
seit einem Monat oder so.
Okay, was gibt's da eigentlich Neues? Lass mal kurz
checken. Irgendwas, warum sich das lohnt zu updaten?
What's new? New Security
Enhancement.
Control Virtual Machine.
Ja, okay.
Windows
Power Management.
Supports 206.
50. Okay, es hat sich also nichts im Endeffekt geändert.
Was für mich irgendwie relevant wäre.
Äh, langweilig.
Ja, mach ich.
Ja, ja.
Also ich war, heute nicht,
aber ich war, heute ist Montag, ne?
Ja, ich war gestern.
Gestern Morgen. Gestern Morgen, bevor
ich Stream-Gel gemacht hab.
Das hab ich mir, das hab ich
mir auch aufgeschrieben, ne? Fix, fix.
Ja, irgendwann.
Demnächst. Keine Ahnung. Wir haben noch so viel Zeug.
Und by the way,
warum auch immer ich noch einen Zettel hier auf hab,
auf Klo.
Tap.
Ich bin nämlich auf Klo.
So, mal kurz Update machen.
Hast du vor, das Update auf, ja.
Echt? Wirklich?
In, inwiefern?
Warum? Ich, also ich hatte bis jetzt,
ich will nicht sagen, noch nie, aber
enorm selten nur Probleme
mit
VMware Update.
Was, was war? Was ist kaputt gegangen?
Moin Chatkin.
So.
Was macht eigentlich
Vmoji
und das Issue
von Discord
Poll Requests?
Haben die das jetzt
gemerged? Wo sind die,
wo sind die Discord, die, die, die
Discord-Five-Header?
Irgendwie finde ich das
nicht mehr. Aber Discord, Discord.
Ja doch, der, der hier ist das doch.
Discord, oder was?
Wir brauchen neuen
Emoji von Release.
Es ist wichtig.
Es ging, also ich hatte bis jetzt noch keine
Probleme. Ich bin gestern Morgen, da war's
glaube ich nur 3 Grad oder sogar
vielleicht sogar noch ein bisschen weniger.
Und
ich kenn weder die eine
Reaction noch die andere Reaction
noch interessiert's mich großartig.
Hast du dir so fancy
Laufbekleidung gekauft?
Definiere fancy.
Ich mach mal kurz
den ganzen, ich, ich review dir jetzt einfach mal.
Du, du, du, du, du, du.
Definiere fancy.
Also, was ich am Start habe ist,
je nachdem, ein bisschen so
nach Temperatur, aber meistens, ich
renne selbst in, ich renne selbst
bei, bei 0
bis 3 Grad noch mit kurzer Hose, aber
da hab ich so, da hab ich so
lange Socken an. Bisschen das, was die Fußballspieler
anhaben, um ihre Schienbeinschützer
zu halten, so.
Ähm, so, so lange Socken
und kurze Hose, dass im Prinzip nur die Knie
rausgucken, das ist warm genug. Wenn's
Minus wird, wenn's Minus wird, dann lange
Hose. Oder wenn's nass ist, lange Hose.
Ne, aber das wär auch mal net schlecht.
Obenrum,
obenrum hab ich allerdings
ein langes, so nen, so nen
Funktions...
äh, Hemd, also was mit, was
schweißdurchlässig ist. Und dann zieh ich
noch meistens so ne gelbe
Jacke, also so ne kurze
gelbe Jacke drüber, dass man das halt ordentlich
sieht. Was war mit Twitch heute
los? TOS-Content auf der
Startseite hab ich nicht gesehen.
Hab ich nicht, was war denn für, was
war denn für TOS-Content auf der Startseite?
Etwa, Cocker?
Ähm...
Ich werde das nicht
aufmachen, Chatge.
Was auch immer, was auch immer das ist,
ich werd das nicht aufmachen. Wenn das wirklich,
wenn das wirklich TOS-Content ist, dann...
Badestreams.
Ja, das ist ja mittlerweile,
so, semi-erlaubt.
Bei den Twitch-Regeln
blickt doch eh keiner mehr durch.
Die Auslegung ist doch auch mal so,
mal so.
Ja, Links, Links von Chainlore sind safe.
Wo ist der eigentlich? Von dem haben wir schon
lange nix mehr gehört.
Keck, Wade, Alter. Ich konns,
ich konns natürlich wieder nicht lassen.
Ich hab auf dem zweiten
Bildschirm doch den Stream aufgemacht.
So scheiß.
Was bin ich sehend,
man, auf Twitch, Alter.
Aber das ist nicht MonkaTOS.
Die hat ja noch was an.
Monka, MonkaTOS,
MonkaTOS wäre das,
wenn die nix mehr anhätte.
Alter.
Was geht auf Twitch ab, man?
Tja. Nix.
Nix, was verpasst.
Bereit, der ASCII-Spam vorzustellen?
Da will wieder gebannt werden. Oh!
Kann es sein, dass der Chainlore nix schreibt,
weil er noch gebannt ist?
Modkes?
Ist er vielleicht noch gebannt?
Wir mussten ihn doch letztens zwar wieder...
Aber wir timeouten den doch nur, gell?
Arbeitest du manchmal mit Chat-GPT?
Ja.
Wobei, arbeiten ist zu viel gesagt.
Lass mich doch gerne manchmal Texte zusammenfassen.
Ist er nicht? Okay.
Texte zusammenfassen oder sowas wie
ich hab keinen Bock da drauf, schreib mal
nette Absage oder so.
Chat-GPT.
Ansonsten, ja.
Wenn sich's mal anbietet.
Also, ich kann euch jetzt erzählen, Chat-GPT,
was wir mal kurz machen müssen.
Umso schneller wir fertig sind,
umso schneller
die Schwarmintelligenz funktioniert,
umso schneller können wir irgendwas anderes
machen.
Ich glaube, für Rust habe ich heute keine Gehirnkapazität,
aber wir können uns vielleicht noch ein
15-Minuten-Video angucken, wo ich wieder
eine Stunde schwätzen muss.
Müssen wir mal gucken, irgendwas können wir noch machen.
Aber wir müssen, ich muss das erst mal für
morgen vorbereiten. Also, ich erzähl euch
jetzt mal, um was es geht.
Also, ich hab ja eigentlich schon Urlaub
bis Januar, aber
wir haben ab morgen, Dienstag und
Mittwoch, noch einen zweitägigen
Teambuilding-Workshop. Allerdings nicht in
Frankfurt, sondern hier in der Nähe
in einem Hotel.
Und ich hab mir jetzt die letzten paar Wochen über immer was
aufgeschrieben, so, wenn mir was auf den Keks gegangen
ist oder wenn ich mir gedacht hab, ey,
das Thema könnte man mal in so einem
Teambuilding thematisieren.
Das Problem ist,
ich hab wild, wild
zusammengeschrieben einfach, nur so komplett
random, so quasi
vom Kopf in das Textdokument.
Das Problem ist, dass das
nicht aussprechbar und
verstehbar ist für Außenstehende.
Außer für euch.
Ihr guckt lange genug zu, ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass das, was ich geschrieben hab,
für euch verständlich ist.
Und da müssen wir jetzt zu jedem,
ich hab insgesamt irgendwie elf Punkte
oder so, und zu jedem Punkt müssen wir zwei, drei
Ne, was heißt freiwillig?
Das ist Arbeitszeit, du kriegst bezahlt.
Freiwillig würde ich da nicht hingehen, wenn's nicht bezahlt wird.
Du hast bestimmt Twitch-E-Modes
reingeschrieben. Ja, ich hab unter anderem
kekwait und sowas ab und zu reingeschrieben.
Warum ist die Musik jetzt unterschiedlich laut?
Was ist denn hier schon wieder los?
Ich hab sehr viel gekekwt
in der Dings und
kekwaitet. Vor allem hab ich kekwaitet.
Ja, und also
wir probieren
das einfach mal, ja?
Business.txt, ja?
Also, Community-Ge...
Wir machen das mal hier...
Nee, komm, wir machen nicht Notepad, Alter.
Was ist das?
Ich hab kein Visual Studio Co... Achso, ja gut,
ich brauch kein Visual Studio Code, weil ich Visual Studio Code
hier hab. Cocker.
Was auch immer das damit zu tun hat.
Ihr seid bereit? Okay, nice.
GG Eats.
Wir speichern das mal hier.
Massive.
Five Head
Chatge.
Okay.
Also.
Moment.
Chinko. Chinko, was ist los?
Okay.
Also. Wie gesagt, je schneller wir
sind, umso schneller ist das Ganze wieder fertig.
Aber ihr müsst Six Head, ihr müsst wirklich Six Head
sein. Das muss
irgendwas taugen, ja? Was da
rauskommt. Ich muss das morgen sagen können
und es muss zu so einem Teambuilding-Workshop passen.
Also ich kann nicht sagen, Gachi
Rollkeg Alu oder sowas.
Wobei,
das kann ich schon sagen.
Möglich, reine Aussprache
möglich ist das. Es wird bloß keiner checken.
Die denken da wie einer Max Laber wieder komisches
Zeug vor sich hin.
Okay, also.
Erster Punkt, den ich mir aufgeschrieben hab.
Ich sage euch erstmal so grob, was ich aufgeschrieben hab.
Da müssen wir irgendwie
was draufbauen. Also, erstes Problem.
Also, wir müssen auch dazu sagen,
das dient dazu, um
die Zusammenarbeit innerhalb der Gruppe zu verbessern.
Ich bin der Meinung, so schlecht ist die Zusammenarbeit
in der Gruppe gar nicht.
Ähm.
Die Probleme, die wir haben, liegen
eigentlich nicht so sehr an der Gruppe selber,
sondern an den Sachen drumherum.
Unter anderem
wird der Workshop durch
einen externen Trainer geführt. Ja.
Also, das erste, was ich mir aufgeschrieben hab, ist,
dass
ich lese euch das
einfach mal vor, ja? Und dann müssen wir da
irgendeinen Satz draus machen. Also, wir können auch
Chat-GPT, wobei, ich will mein Dokument,
da stehen Namen drin und so, ich will das Dokument
hier nirgendwo reinpacen. Also, ich hab mir aufgeschrieben,
erstens, man rechnet
eine Person immer,
ich muss das ein bisschen langsamer lesen, weil ich mir manchmal
nicht sicher bin, ob ich was, was Geheimes
reingeschrieben hab oder so.
Also, ich brauch übrigens passende,
passende Untermalung
dazu. Beste.
Also,
man rechnet immer eine Person,
nein, man rechnet, ich kann auch nicht mal
mein eigenes Zeug lesen. Alter.
Man rechnet eine Person immer
100%, die man verplanen könnte,
aber das stimmt nicht.
Mich mit 80%
eh mal ausgenommen.
Weil es so viel Grundrauschen
gibt, dass es realistischer
ist, 60%,
wenn nicht 50% sind.
Ihr stellt vielleicht fest, die Sätze
ergeben grammatikalisch
keinen Sinn, aber ich glaub, man versteht,
was ich, was ich mir da gedacht hab bei.
Ähm,
so.
Zu viele, zu viele, zu viele
Meetings.
Ja, ich mein, Meeting gehört
ja irgendwie manchmal dazu.
Ich, wie gesagt, ich hab
das, ich hab das direkt
Kopftext gedumpt.
Ich hab mir gedacht, ich schreib das irgendwann nochmal ordentlich.
So, ähm,
ja, das ist schön,
aber das wird nicht
gesehen und mit eingerechnet.
Ich kann am Tag nur 50%
arbeiten, weil 50%
irgendwas anderes sind.
Ich muss doch jetzt
kein Screenshot vom Kalender zeigen.
So.
Das ist,
das ist das erste, was
ich mir aufgeschrieben hab. Also, ich würd mal sagen,
den Punkt
können wir zusammenfassen mit
zu vielen Meetings und
also es sei denn,
Moment, es geht, es geht ja noch weiter.
Es geht ja noch weiter. Ich habe noch mehr dazu aufgeschrieben.
Okay, das ist Free Money.
Das stimmt, das stimmt. Ich hab auch
überhaupt keine Probleme mit Meetings.
Ich hab das Problem, das ist, okay, ich erklär
das einfach mal, was ich meine, ja.
Ähm,
das finde ich ist ne gute, das ist ne gute Sache.
Das ist ne gute Sache, ja, das ist ne gute, Chat,
Chat, Pfeifert, ja.
Das ist, das ist ne gute, gute Frage.
Also, was ich meine ist folgendes.
Ich hab überhaupt gar keine Probleme,
wenn gemietet wird. Wenn, ich, mach
ich ja auch. Wenn die Firma will,
dass man, ähm, mietet
und die das bezahlen, dann miete ich auch.
Das, was ich doof finde, finde ist,
eigentlich
ist zu viele Meetings ist falsch. Das stimmt
nicht. Ich habe überhaupt kein Problem mit zu viele Meetings.
Was mir nicht gefällt
ist, dass 100%
der Leute die Zeit geplant
wird, von den 100% sind
allerdings bloß 50% was, wo man
machen kann. Versteht ihr?
Versteht ihr, was ich meine? Das kennt doch wahrscheinlich
jeder von euch. Oder die, oder
viele von euch kennen das wahrscheinlich.
Ja, das so in der Richtung,
ja. Also, sag mal,
das ist, das ist aber, das,
das ist eine gute Frage. Das lasse
ich mal hier drinnen. Also,
ich würde sagen, zu
viele Meetings ist vielleicht,
machen wir mal ein Fragezeichen dahinter.
Also eigentlich, eigentliches Problem
ist doch eigentlich, man
rechnet eine Person
gleich, gleich,
Alter, ich kann
gleich 100%
außer mich mit 80
lul. Ähm,
ich kann kein normales Deutsch
mehr schreiben. Das ist unmöglich.
Ja, man rechnet eine Person
gleich 100%
und das
erwarten dann zum Beispiel
die
Projekte auch. Okay,
ja, versteht man, versteht man ja was gemein ist.
Aber durch
das ganze Grundrauschen
und
Meetings und
ja, äh,
Overhead,
bloat, bloated overhead, bloat.
Wir schreiben einfach bloat.
Ähm,
sind es am Ende nur
50 bis 60%. Okay,
ich glaube,
das ist gut.
Das, das
kann man, das kann man denke ich so lassen.
So, dann habe ich mir noch was dazu aufgeschrieben und zwar,
also ich, ich würde gerne,
ich würde gerne diesen Punkt überleiten
zu, zu was
anderem, aber davor, ich habe mir noch ein bisschen mehr
dazu aufgeschrieben und zwar,
ähm, so bei uns
gehen nämlich irgendwann auch Leute in Rente.
Und da frage ich mich, wie das dann werden soll.
Ein
weiterer Punkt ist, wir können
genau, das ist, das,
das, das muss auch noch rein, Chat.
Das muss auch noch ein Wissenstransfer,
sehr gut, sehr gut. Wissenstransfer
hält
flach,
nicht flach, flach
fällt oft flach.
Zum Beispiel
weekly, ähm,
wir haben weekly so, so
ja,
wie nennt, wie nennt man das?
Ich weiß gar nicht,
wie das richtig heißt bei uns.
Ja, wir haben so eine, wir haben so einen wöchentlichen Termin,
wo die Leute irgendwas
vorstellen können aus ihrem Bereich, damit die
andere das mitkriegen. Ähm,
findet fast
nie statt.
Moment, es denkt, Moment,
denkt der, das ist,
Alter, der denkt, es ist ein Kubernetes Manifest.
Ja, ich finde, es sieht,
sieht auch schon ganz hart aus, am Kubernetes Manifest,
heißt man. Außerdem ist das
kein Jammel. Das ist einfach
Markdown.
So. Ja.
So. Und dann
habe ich hier noch aufgeschrieben
für die Frage. Also, ich habe
nämlich, ich antizipiere nämlich schon,
dass
die Frage kommt.
Die Frage wird kommen. Und vielleicht
kennt ihr diese Frage auch. Wenn man so
Punkte bringt, wird dann die Frage kommen.
Macht es denn Sinn,
an allem teilzunehmen?
Und da
muss man halt ganz klar sagen,
potenziell schon.
Man weiß ja die genauen Inhalte nicht.
Und es kann ja gut sein,
dass es wichtige Infos gibt.
Und man bei manchen Punkten
was zu sagen will.
Und wenn man dann nicht hingeht,
heißt es am Ende, ja, wärst du
da gewesen, da wurde das doch gesagt.
Ja.
Das muss ich auch noch irgendwie
hier aufnehmen.
Da machen wir mal 1.1 raus.
Sind alle Meetings sinnvoll?
Nein, aber das weiß man ja vorher nicht.
Wir haben letztens darüber gesprochen,
ob wir einen Tunneltag einbauen.
Einen Tag ohne Meetings, ohne.
Ja, ja, das wäre vielleicht auch nicht
verkehrt.
Nicht so schlimm ist das nicht.
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
So schlimm ist das nicht.
Das hat sich jetzt schlimmer angehört,
als es ist.
Aber ich meine, es ist doch, es ist doch
nachvollziehbar, wenn man sagt Okay,
ich habe zu viele Meetings.
Ich weiß nicht, ich sage jetzt einfach
mal ein paar davon ab, dass dann im Endeffekt
war doch was Wichtiges gesagt wird.
Das ist auch so ein Punkt.
Bei den meisten Meetings.
Wird tatsächlich.
Also nicht explizit was festgehalten,
sondern es werden danach, wenn die Leute
dran denken, irgendwelche Tickets draus
generiert oder nicht.
Ich finde das aber auch gut.
Ganz ehrlich, Protokolle sind komplett
useless. Protokolle guckt niemand rein
und jeder ist abgefuckt, wenn er sie schreiben
muss.
Wenn es wirklich wichtige Sachen gibt,
das ist was anderes.
Aber dieses normale 0815, ähm, keine Ahnung.
Habt ihr schon gesehen, dass hier wieder
ein Sambascher weg ist oder sowas?
Das musste nirgendswo schriftlich festhalten.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
kein Protokoll.
Kein.
Ja, habe ich aber nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt.
Kein Protokoll.
Ich hasse Protokolle.
Das macht niemand.
In der Theorie klingt es immer gut.
Seriously, Leute, Hand aufs Herz.
Ja, aber ich habe nicht auf die Reihe gekriegt. Kein Protokoll. Ich hasse Protokolle. Das macht niemand. In der Theorie klingt es immer gut. Seriously, Leute, Hand aufs Herz.
Wer von euch guckt sich Team-Protokolle, also Team-Meeting-Protokolle an, wenn er nicht da war?
Wer guckt die sich an?
Wir machen mal, okay, wir machen mal...
Wir machen mal, wir machen mal ne Abstimmung.
Wir machen mal ne Abstimmung, okay?
Ich sage, die wenigsten, die wenigen gucken sich das an.
Guckt ihr in alle rein, wenn ihr nicht da war?
So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, dass es datenschutztechnisch nicht drin ist, aufzunehmen.
Wenn es keine Protokolle gibt, dann guckst du nicht rein.
Ich gebe dir recht, sowas ist nicht schlecht.
Aber ich habe das vorgeschlagen, ganz am Anfang mal, dass wir so einen Daily-Labor-Teams-Channel machen.
Aber irgendwie wollen sie das nicht.
Das ist auch noch ein Punkt, da kommen wir gleich zu.
Okay, also die wenigsten gucken sich wirklich Protokolle oft an, wenn sie in den Meetings nicht waren.
Das ist auch meine, das ist auch ehrlich gesagt meine Erfahrung, dass so gut wie niemand diese Protokolle anguckt.
Das ist meistens verschwendete Mühe und die Leute, die Protokolle schreiben müssen, ja, so dachte ich mir das auch, die sind abgefuckt.
So, also, sind alle Meetings sinnvoll?
Nein, das weiß man vorher nicht, das ist ja das Ding.
Also muss man ja, muss man ja quasi sagen, potenziell, schreibt man das überhaupt so?
Potenziell?
Potenziell, alles klar.
Potenziell schon, man weiß ja nicht genau, was dran kommt.
Oder, oder ob es Fragen eingibt.
Außerdem, wenn man jetzt anfängt, random Meetings abzusagen.
Ja, aber, gut, es geht, ich muss auch ehrlich sagen, es gibt auch viele Sinnlose, da gehe ich auch gar nicht hin, aber es sind trotzdem noch zu viele.
Ich sehe das genauso, ich finde das vollkommen in Ordnung, dass man öfters meetet.
Ich finde das vollkommen in Ordnung, allerdings, wenn es in Zusammenhang hiermit kommt, ist das Problem.
So, und das ist, das schreibe ich mir jetzt nur auf für den Fall der Fälle, dass jemand mit dem Standardargument um die Ecke kommt.
Ja, dann muss man halt paar Meetings machen.
Ja, dann muss man halt paar Meetings absagen, das geht halt nicht.
Ja, weil man nicht weiß, wer ist da gewesen, hättest du es mitbekommen.
So, kommen dann so Aussagen.
Okay, so, erster Punkt, würde ich sagen, finished.
Es gibt ja kein ihr in dem Fall, das sind ja immer unterschiedliche Sachen.
Es sind ja nicht immer die gleichen Leute dabei, das ist immer ganz unterschiedlich.
Und man muss sagen, bei ungefähr...
Bei ungefähr der Hälfte, würde ich sagen.
Bei ungefähr der Hälfte haben wir eine Agenda, bei ungefähr der Hälfte nicht.
Das sind aber auch oftmal Sachen, die kann man...
Das ist sehr schwierig, da irgendwelche Agendas, weil wer soll das machen, das ist ja schon wieder das nächste Problem.
Was kann das...
Ich habe morgen ein Teambuilding-Workshop und ich dachte mir, anstatt, dass wir irgendwelche blöden Gruppenspielchen machen,
so irgendwie, wir spielen Topfschlagen oder verstecken uns im Wald oder machen eine Schnitzeljagd oder was auch immer,
was sich dann so Trainer, so tolle Sachen ausdenken, habe ich gesagt, ich dachte ich mir so,
ich bringe mal ein paar Themen mit, die wirklich was bringen würden, drüber zu reden.
So, und, also ich würde sagen, ich würde sagen, jetzt haben wir den ersten Punkt, haben wir, haben wir jetzt.
Jetzt kommen wir, jetzt kommen wir zum nächsten Punkt.
Und das ist auch was, was mich übelst, was mich übelst nervt.
Und zwar, wenn man dann...
Halbafg...
So, wenn man dann mal mit Leuten über irgendwas mietet, wie gesagt, da kommt das eine zum anderen.
Wenn man dann mal wirklich mit Leuten über irgendwas mietet, was ich, was ich für wichtig halte,
oder wo es um irgendwas geht, wo man gerade dran arbeitet oder so,
da sind die Leute eben genau wegen diesem Punkt hier halbafg, weil sie halb im Meeting sind und halb am Arbeiten.
Halb am Mieten, halb am Arbeiten.
Ja.
Und das ist, das, da gibt es dann, das ist, das ist super nervig.
Dann sagt irgendjemand was, oder du sagst es, und, äh, dann denkt man, fragt man dann so nach dem Motto,
ja, hier, Peter, äh, was sagst du dazu?
Und dann hörst du so richtig, tick, tick, tick, und irgendwie so nach drei Sekunden, vier Sekunden unmutet sich Peter dann,
und sagt dann so, äh, ja, wie war nochmal die Frage?
So, das nervt mich so, das zieht die Sache nochmal unnötig in die Länge.
Ich bin mir sicher, das liegt daran, das liegt daran, weil die Leute 100% verplant sind, 100% machen,
oder, ja, zumindest das Gefühl haben, 100% machen zu müssen,
aber sie sind in irgendwelchen Meetings und sind, sie machen nichts Halbes und nichts Ganzes.
Ich mach das übrigens auch so, ja, ja, ja, ich mach das auch so.
Christian, danke schön für den Sub.
Sagt, so.
Das reicht eigentlich, wenn man das so schreiben.
Du hast Text-to-Speech mitlaufen lassen.
Das ist auch ne gute Idee, das ist auch ne gute Idee.
So, also das ist, das ist mein nächster Punkt.
Halb AFK wäre ein Call, halb Amiten, halb, aber nichts Halbes und nichts Ganzes.
Ja, und das liegt, das liegt an Punkt 1.
Sag ich euch ganz klar.
Das ist, das ist, das ist echt das Problem, aus meiner Sicht, ja.
Dann kann ich, da kann ich schon mal die Hälfte löschen aus meinem Textdokument, da weiß ich,
da hab ich das hier schon.
So, nächster Punkt, dritter Punkt.
So, so.
Wie gesagt, da kommt, ohne Scheiß, da kommt eins, eins zum anderen.
Durch diese ganzen Sachen, dadurch, dass auch Wissenstransfer oft flach fällt und unser
Weekly-Austausch oftmals nicht stattfindet, ist drittens, ist auch so ein Punkt, es sind
sehr viele Einzelkämpfer, sehr viele Einzelkämpfer unterwegs.
Jeder beschäftigt sich, die Musik, Spooky, Spooky-Musik.
Passt ja auch dazu.
Ja, das ist auch nervig.
Nee, ich hab morgen einen Teambuilding-Workshop und ich dachte mir, anstatt, bevor wir irgendwelche
blöden Gruppenspielchen machen, bringe ich mal ein paar Sachen mit, die man wirklich mal
drüber reden könnte, ja?
Nee, nee, das ist, das ist gar nicht so, das, das ist wirklich nicht so.
Bei uns, wir haben, wir haben im Team sehr viele Leute, die sagen alle sehr gerne was
und sind immer auch der Meinung, dass ihre Sache, ich ja auch, ich bin ja auch so schlimm,
ja?
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Sache, ähm, das eisig wahre ist, so, aber die sind schon hilfsbereit
untereinander.
Das kann man, das, also es liegt nicht daran, dass die Leute sich nicht abkönnen oder nicht
miteinander arbeiten wollen.
Ja, wenn sie nicht wollen, ist auch gut, dann sollen sie halt irgendwelche komischen Gruppenspielchen,
irgendwelche komischen Gruppenspielchen machen, aber dann muss man sich nicht wundern, wenn
das nichts bringt, ja?
Aber gerade sowas, dass wir sehr viele Einzelkämpfer haben.
Das ist was, ich denke, das ist genau richtig bei einem Teambuilding Workshop.
Das liegt aber auch genau da dran, das liegt zum größten Teil da dran und ich hab mir
dazu aufgeschrieben, so, wir haben sehr viele Einzelkämpfer, ich auch, ich auch, ich auch,
das ist ein guter Punkt, es sind alle da, also alle, das, das, das, das schreibe ich
mal auf.
Das schreibe ich mal auf.
Das ist ein guter Punkt.
Das ist ein guter Punkt, Chat.
Es ist alle, also es sind, es sind bis auf Teamleiter-Ebene, also die Leute im Team und
der Chef sind da, also man kann da schon sinnvollerweise was besprechen, ja?
So, also was ich, was ich mir aufgeschrieben habe zu dem Thema, den hätte ich erst recht
nicht wieder geholt, den hätte ich erst recht nicht wieder geholt, den hätte ich mir lieber
irgendeinen Solaris-Consultant oder so bestellt für, für ein halbes Jahr, nämlich, also
Wir müssen mal vorwärts, Leute, wir kommen überhaupt nicht, kommen überhaupt nicht,
also, wir haben, wir haben sehr viele Einzelkämpfer und dazu hab ich mir aufgeschrieben, das liegt
nicht daran, dass wir irgendwie uns nicht abkönnen untereinander und dass man quasi
erstmal Schnitzeljagd im Wald machen muss, damit wir uns, damit wir uns alle wieder mögen,
das ist, das ist eigentlich Blödsinn, das liegt einfach so an den, an den unterschiedlichen
Aufgaben.
Ja.
nichts miteinander zu tun haben wollen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das...
Wie könnte man das ordentlich begründen?
Also, wenn ich...
Also, was ich erlebt habe, ist, wenn die
Leute miteinander sich mal hinsetzen und was
machen, dann
funktioniert das wunderbar.
Nur meistens kommt es nicht dazu.
Aber das liegt nicht da dran,
weil die Leute sich nicht abkönnen.
Das
liegt eigentlich eher daran,
weil sich halt jeder um seinen eigenen Scheiß
kümmern muss.
Ja, dann ist Einzelkämpfer
das falsche Wort.
Isolierte Arbeits...
Das klingt super
High-IQ-mäßig. Können wir das auch
irgendwie so beschreiben, dass
jeder versteht? Nein, nein,
das trifft es auch nicht.
Ist sie los? Ja,
das ist ganz gut.
Isolierte. Ja, wir schreiben.
Liegt nicht daran,
dass die Leute
sich
nicht abkönnen.
Sondern
sowas, sowas in der Richtung. Ja, das trifft
isolierte
Silos.
Richtig, das ist gut. Das ist gut.
Es ist schneller, das Ding selbst zu
machen, als sich zusammen
zu setzen, weil alle überlastet
sind.
Wissens
Transfer schreiben wir da nochmal hin.
Okay? Perfekt. Reicht.
Dritter Punkt erledigt. Dritter Punkt erledigt. Das ist okay.
Das ist gut. Genau das
trifft. Das wird dann nämlich nicht gemacht.
Weil es einfach schneller ist,
derjenige, der sich schon damit auskennt,
auskennt,
sich zusammenzusetzen. Ja, ja, ja.
Überlastet ist aber das Falschwort.
Weil, ja doch.
Ja, ja, ja. Lassen wir es
mal so stehen. Lassen wir es mal so stehen.
Und alle mit
ihrem eigenen Kram.
So, nennen wir es mal so.
Vielleicht kann man das noch ein bisschen
pitten. Wir sind kein
Anwendungsentwickler-Team.
Ja,
das bräuchten wir eh. Ich bin mal gespannt.
Bei uns gehen demnächst auch ein paar Leute in Rente.
Die waren früher, by the way, auch Solaris-Admins.
Und
im eigenen Mikrokosmos.
Das ist auch eine sehr schöne
Umschreibung. Das finde ich gut.
Siehst du, Chat? Es hat sich
es hat sich
schon wieder gelohnt,
dass ihr am Start seid. Im eigenen
Mikrokosmos. Das ist
Sixth-Head-Formulierung.
Das ist so typische. Im eigenen
Mikrokosmos. Das ist so richtige.
Das könnte so ein richtiger Manager-Bullshit-Satz
sein. Finde ich gut.
Ich glaube, ich habe FFZ
hier nicht an. Ah, doch, ne.
Sind bei dir auch Devs im Team?
Nein.
Die ist einfach zu Community-ge.
Ja, wir haben auch
Doku-Dinger. Das Problem
ist nur, dass halt jeder sein Zeug
Also erstens, OneNote.
Ich hasse OneNote.
Die Suche von OneNote ist einfach
Schrott. Kannst keine
Substrings suchen. Ist einfach
mir fällt da kein nettes Wort für
eins. Einfach Dreck.
Confluence-Suche ist
auch Kacke. Also
das Ding ist
OneNote-Page
für alles und jeden.
Dann findest du auch alles und jedes wieder.
Okay,
nächster Punkt. Chat geht. Sonst wird das
nichts. Nächster Punkt.
Weiß ich nicht, ob wir den reinschreiben sollten.
Ich glaube, der hat im
Teambuilding nichts zu tun. Ist aber auch ein Punkt, den ich mir
aufgeschrieben habe. Aber ich glaube,
das lassen wir
weg. Ich habe
geschrieben, die Komplexität ist
zu hoch. Entweder du weißt
es oder bist fünf Jahre plus dabei
und hast es mal gehört
und weißt, in welchem der hundert Doku-Systeme
man suchen muss
oder man hat verloren.
Doku ist ja schön
und gut,
aber man hat halt trotzdem keine Ahnung, wo und in welchem
System. Naja, das hat mit Teambuilding
nichts zu tun. Das lassen wir weg.
So, dann ist mir ein Punkt aufgefallen.
Der, finde ich, der hat,
den müsste man eigentlich mal im Teambuilding
ansprechen, weil, das habe ich schon von
einigen Leuten gesehen, gerade von Leuten,
die schon länger dabei sind.
Die haben eine gewisse
nervige
Art
zu
die Leute
in ihre Richtung zu
dazu zu drängen, das zu machen, was sie wollen.
Ich kann das nicht anders zu erzählen.
Und das trifft nicht wirklich mein Team direkt,
also auch, da haben wir auch ein paar Leute,
die sowas in der Richtung machen, aber
das ist so ein Ding, das habe ich allgemein,
das habe ich allgemein schon erlebt.
Also, zum Beispiel,
nicht nörgeln, ich, ich, mal ein Beispiel,
mal ein Beispiel, ja.
Nichts, was passiert ist, sondern
das denke ich mir jetzt aus, ja.
Also, zum Beispiel,
wenn man irgendwie drüber redet,
Moment.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Also, was ich meine, ist folgendes.
Also, stellt, stellt euch mal vor,
ähm, irgendein
Server ist kaputt,
einer von den Systemen, die ihr nicht kennt,
weil ihr nicht für zuständig seid, ja.
Aber, ihr lockt euch trotzdem mal
drauf ein und guckt
und danach in irgendeinem
Daily oder so, redet ihr da drüber.
Und dann gibt es Leute,
die ungefähr,
also, dann, dann sagt man, okay,
ey, ich war auf dem System eingeloggt, aber
also, an den üblichen Stellen
war nix und,
äh, ich konnt auf, ich konnt
auf die Schnelle nicht sehen, was, was der, was
der Server für Probleme hat. So.
Stellt euch, stellt euch vor, sagt ihr, sagt ihr, ja.
Und dann gibt es Leute, die antworten
da drauf, sowas wie,
ja, aber du hast doch
sicher in dem und dem System
reingeschaut.
Also hast du doch sicher auch gesehen,
dass das und das das Problem ist.
Kennt ihr das?
Leute, die einem mit der
Frage, was in Mund,
da gibt es auch ein Wort für, da gibt es auch,
ein Wort für. Mir fällt's grad nicht
ein. Es gibt,
es gibt, das ist so ne Taktik,
ja, das ist, das ist, ja, genau,
das mein ich, ja, genau, das mein ich.
Dass man den Leuten versucht,
was quasi, egal
wie sie drauf antworten,
das in den Mund zu legen,
dass sie sich entweder
direkt verteidigen müssen,
oder, aber das ist nicht so schlimm,
das ist so ganz, aber es gibt ein paar Leute,
die haben da echt so den Hang dazu.
Das ist aber, genau, das, das,
gut. Das, das trifft's ganz
gut. Das, ich finde, da sollte man
sich mal echt an die eigene Nase fragen,
fassen, wie was ankommt.
Ja, das sollte man sich so
allgemein fragen. Ich versuch, ich mach so was
auch manchmal, ja, aber
ich, ich,
ich versuch mich, ich versuch mich bei so was
immer ein bisschen zusammenzureißen,
mir zu überlegen, okay,
wie, wie würdest, wie würdest
du das finden, wenn
einer so was, ich mein, klappt trotzdem nicht,
ja, ich, nervt bestimmt
auch genug, Leute.
Ja, das kann man so nicht,
das kann man so nicht so sagen, das ist viel zu hart,
aber,
ja, das, das, da brauch ich ein gutes Beispiel
für, ja.
Ohne Mist,
also, ich hab mit den Leuten kein, also, ich hab mit
nicht ein, es gibt ein paar Leute, die sind,
ja, ich weiß, ich geh auch
manchmal auf den Keks, es gibt ein paar, die sind ein bisschen mehr oder
weniger nervig, aber ich hab mit keinem
irgendwie ein großartiges Problem. Das hatte
ich auf der alten Arbeit mehr, da gab's Leute, die haben mich
richtig abgefuckt. Im Großen und Ganzen
ist das echt meckern auf hohem Niveau.
Die sind eigentlich auch projektübergreifend
so eigentlich zum größten Teil wirklich
nett, die Leute. Die haben halt so ihre
Eigenheiten, aber ganz ehrlich, IT-Leute
haben alle ihre Eigenheiten.
Einfach nicht drauf eingehen.
Ne, das
Beste, was man machen kann, aus meiner,
meiner Meinung nach, wenn man das erkennt, ist,
direkt zu sagen,
dass du dann sagst, ja, okay,
was soll ich denn da drauf
jetzt antworten, ja?
So wie du das darstellst,
ja, hätten wir es doch, hätten wir es,
wissen müssen, oder wie? Also, ich glaube, es ist
gar nicht, es ist, es macht keinen Sinn, direkt
darauf einzugehen und das anzunehmen,
was der, was der, was, was man quasi
im Mund gelegt kriegt, sondern man muss direkt sagen,
ähm,
dass das
quasi, was einem was im Mund liegt, was, was
so nicht gesagt wurde, dann, dann ist auch gut.
Ja.
Ja, es, es gibt, also wir müssen, wir müssen auch
nochmal hier, was der, nachher ist
man immer schlauer,
ja? So nach dem Motto,
so,
hast du, heute, warum hast
du am Sonntag
nicht die, nicht
die richtigen
Lottozahlen
getippt? So.
So nach dem Motto,
heute weiß man sie ja.
So, weißt du, also, so nach dem
Motto, ja, man hat eine halbe Stunde drüber
geredet, aber es ist halt ein Unterschied,
ob man an einem System sitzt, was gerade
kaputt ist und alle sind am Schreien,
oder ob man zwei Stunden Zeit hat,
sich darüber Gedanken,
zu machen, ja, sowas.
Okay, ähm,
und am Ende müssen wir uns noch die
Top-Punkte raussuchen, die, die ich,
weil ich glaube nicht, dass ich alle Sachen,
also viel Zeit ist da gar nicht.
So. Das nächste, das nächste
finde ich auch, das nächste ist auch so ein Ding,
das ist, glaube ich, eher so mit den Leuten,
wo ich, wo ich, äh,
mehr zusammenarbeite,
der Fall, wir zerdiskutieren
enorm viel
und lassen uns super leicht
sidetracken.
Nennt mich, ich bin der Meister-Side-Side-Tracker,
kennt sich der, ja, ja, haben wir auch schon benutzt,
hier im Stream sogar.
Ja, äh,
wir
zerdiskutieren
vieles
und lassen uns super leicht
sidetracken.
Beispiel, Beispiel.
Wir haben einen Daily, das ist für
15 Minuten angesetzt.
Derjenige, der als erstes
sein Thema sagen kann,
hat gewonnen.
Da wird 15 Minuten darüber diskutiert.
Und das ist eigentlich nicht Sinn und Zweck
der Sache. Derjenige,
der im Daily anfangen darf,
ja,
erst was sagt,
abhört das Daily. Schreiben wir es mal so was,
schreiben wir es mal ungefähr so hin.
Ja. Ich meine, dazu,
dazu gibt es kein, die Lösung
dazu ist ganz einfach.
Die Lösung dazu ist ganz einfach,
ähm,
Schieb auf Nacht Daily.
Da gibt es wieder Leute, die sagen,
ey, aber das gehört doch zum Daily dazu.
Da muss man sich halt mal was überlegen.
Nee, kannst du nicht, kannst du nicht immer machen.
Daily geht es ja gerade.
Oh.
Nee, das ist zu, zu over,
zu overkill.
Ich mag Protokolle auch nicht.
Nee, nö, nö, nö, nö.
Das ist ja auch noch so ein Punkt,
dass ich gefühlt meinen Chef dreimal, dreimal gesprochen habe, seitdem er Chef ist.
Ja.
Ich schreibe einfach nur mal alles auf, was mir so einfällt.
Wir müssen es dann noch ein bisschen, wir, wir brauchen dann noch die Top Points da draus,
die man, die man halt, also,
wir, wir, also wir zerdiskutieren vieles und lassen uns mega leicht sidetracken.
Ja.
Und das ist auch noch so ein Punkt,
alle reden durcheinander.
Ähm, also das, das ist halt auch so ein Ding,
wenn was ist,
wo alle der Meinung sind, was zu sagen zu können, dann sagen alle gleichzeitig was.
Das ist ganz, das ist ganz schrecklich.
Und die hören dann auch nicht auf.
Also, normalerweise ist es ja so, wenn jetzt, wenn, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel sag, äh, Chatkill,
ich, ich finde Lulwee deutlich besser als Keckwee.
So, da könnt ihr sagen, 20 Leute, nein Max, das stimmt nicht, alle gleichzeitig.
Aber sobald, sobald dann irgendwie, normalerweise einigt man sich da so ungeschrieben dann da drauf,
wer denn jetzt weitermachen darf, ja.
Entweder der, der am lautesten schreit oder der, der am hartnäckigsten ist oder irgendwas.
Aber,
die schwätzen dann teilweise mit 4 Mann durcheinander für 10 Minuten.
Das ist ganz schrecklich, Mann.
Ja.
Hehe, Redeball, ja, äh.
So, und dazu würde ich sagen,
immer dran denken,
wir reden über Teams, das heißt, 1, 2, 6, leck.
Das muss man nämlich mal dazu sagen.
Leute, die Online-Spiele-Erfahrungen haben, wissen das eigentlich, wie man, äh, äh,
in, in Discord und Teams und,
wie früher war es noch, Teamspeak und sowas, ordentlich reden kann,
ohne dass man sich ins Wort fällt, aber irgendwie, und obwohl ich weiß,
dass da ein paar Leute Online-Spiele-Erfahrungen haben aus meinem Team,
kriegen sie es oftmals nicht richtig hin.
Wobei, doch, der eine, von dem ich es definitiv weiß,
oder auch die zwei, von denen ich es definitiv weiß, die kriegen es hin.
So, dann machen wir das doch mal weg.
So, und das ist eine Sache, die sag ich jetzt hier,
die, die werde ich dann nicht zur Sprache bringen, aber das ist auch so ein Ding.
Bei uns hat jeder so ein bisschen so seine Lieblingsthemen, worüber er redet.
So.
Und die ziehen das teilweise auch ganz knallhart durch, ja.
Der eine kommt immer mit so Dingern, also, ich habe ja auch schon meinen Spruch,
der immer kommt, ja.
Also, bei uns ist das, bei uns ist das meistens so, also, es geht, es geht um irgendein Thema,
ja.
Und dann kommen dann so, so super random Einwürfe, so nach dem Motto, was weiß ich, stellt euch
mal vor, ich würde euch jetzt erzählen, ja, es gibt Probleme mit der, mit der, äh,
Storage-Replizierung in der
Google Cloud. So. Das ist einfach mal
ein fiktives Beispiel. Formless Beastmore,
danke schön für den Sub. Ja, zum Beispiel.
Stellt euch vor, ihr könntet
jetzt zugucken, so bei unserem Team-Meeting
und ich würde erzählen, ja Leute, übrigens
es gibt gerade Probleme bei der
Storage-Replikation in Google.
So, dann kommt der Erste mit
sowas ganz
wirrem um die Ecke und sagt,
ja, hält Google denn auch den Abstand
zwischen ihren Rechenzentren ein?
Und dann denkst du dir so,
oh, was?
Was zum Teufel hat das
damit zu tun?
Das ist nicht wirklich
off-topic, aber auch nicht wirklich
on-topic. So.
Dann kommt der Nächste um die Ecke.
Das wurde doch auf
Meeting YYZ vor zwei Monaten
mal so besprochen und
die dritte Fußnote
von unten sagt, dass man das an passender
Stelle anbringen soll.
Der Nächste ist AFK am Tippen, weil er
gerade eigentlich was arbeiten muss.
Der Nächste kommt um die Ecke und sagt,
ja, mach das bloß nicht auf Ubuntu, das ist
nicht supported. Und dann komme ich um die Ecke
und sage, Jungs, wir sollten jetzt langsam mal anfangen.
So laufen
so laufen total oft unsere
Dailies, Mann.
So richtig random Zeug.
Not helpful, ja.
Nicht richtig off-topic,
aber auch nicht richtig
on-topic.
Topic.
So, machen wir das mal weiter.
Genau, das
eins, eins, genau, eins, was ich
hier, was ich gut fände, so als
Lösung, als Lösung
dafür, ja.
Es wäre nice,
wenn
sich alle bei Fragen
auf den Kern
konzentrieren würden.
Ähm
und
ich weiß nicht, wie ich das
schreiben soll, Leute.
Ich hab den Eindruck und ich mach sowas auch manchmal.
Es ist, wie gesagt, ich nehm mich bei den ganzen
Sachen nicht aus. Ich hab so den Eindruck,
ähm
dass Leute absichtlich
das falsch verstehen,
um dann doch wieder ihr Thema ansprechen
zu können. Wisst ihr, wisst ihr, wie ich mein?
Also, also man weiß doch,
wie es gemeint ist. Man weiß doch, okay,
Beispiel, Beispiel, Beispiel.
Ähm
wenn ich euch jetzt sage,
wie gesagt, auch wieder
ausgedacht, wenn ich euch jetzt sage,
hey Leute, es
gab
eine
Monitoring-Meldung,
daraufhin
haben wir
Service XY neu gestartet
und dann kam es zu
zwei Folgefehlern.
Und jetzt müssen wir mal gucken,
warum das Monitoring so komische Dinger macht.
So, und
dann kommt dann nicht irgendwie der Einwand,
okay, ähm
was könnte mit dem Monitoring verkehrt sein?
Nein, dann kommt dann, da kommt dann der Hinweis,
ähm,
das war doch gar kein Folgefehler, das war doch
eine Folgemeldung.
Versteht ihr, sowas mein ich.
Sowas mein ich. Also, äh,
wäre es nicht, wäre es nicht sinnvoll,
wenn jemand eine Frage stellt,
wenn jemand was sagt,
den,
den Kern
dessen
zu erkent... sich
sich Mühe zu geben,
den Kern einer Frage zu erkennen.
Ne, das so wirk... das ist noch nicht mal böse gemeint,
glaube ich, an der Stelle.
Ah, das finde ich, finde ich gut, ja.
Ja, also, so quasi
versuchen
den, ähm,
...mit versuchen den Kern zu erkennen, ja, den Kern
zu erk... kennen... so.
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich es anders beschreiben soll.
Weil, seriously.
Es ist eigentlich jedem klar, was gemeint ist.
Es ist vollkommen egal, ob man Folgemeldung oder Folgefehler sagt.
Es ist vollkommen klar, was gemeint ist.
Ja, so.
Schreiben wir es mal so.
Wir müssen weitermachen, Chats.
Sonst wäre das nichts.
Ähm.
Korinth Kaka.
Ja, das würde ich so nicht schreiben.
Ja, aber so versuchen, den Kern zu erkennen.
Ich erinnere, ich erwische mich auch manchmal dabei,
dass wenn einer was sagt, wenn es ein Thema ist,
wozu ich Ahnung habe,
dass ich dann unbedingt nochmal erwähnen muss,
dass ich mich damit auch rauskenne.
Oder irgendwas in der Richtung.
Es ist so.
Also versuchen, quasi so den Kern zu erkennen
und darauf zu konzentrieren, weil dann geht es auch schneller.
Was machen wir gerade?
Ich habe morgen ein zweitägiges Teambuilding
und ich wollte mir ein paar Punkte,
ich habe mir so eine random Liste mit Punkten aufgeschrieben
und ich wollte da mal was Verarbeitbares draus machen.
Ich dachte mir, der High-IQ-Chat kann mir dabei helfen
und hat, funktioniert ja auch gut, funktioniert ja auch gut, ja.
Also das finde ich ganz gut.
So, nächster, nächster Punkt.
Äh, wir ziehen Sachen zu lang.
Äh, manchmal geht es 30 Minuten.
Na gut, das habe ich, das habe ich ja hier oben schon.
Das, das habe ich ja hier schon,
wie dass wir vieles, vieles diskutieren
und super leicht sidetracken lassen.
Das habe ich ja schon.
Ähm.
Hier habe ich, ich habe es, Leute,
ich habe es viel besser aufgeschrieben schon in meinem Dokument,
was ich hier sagen wollte.
Und zwar, ich habe mir aufgeschrieben,
versuchen die Essenz zu verändern.
Ähm.
Versuchen die Essenz zu verstehen von dem, was gesagt wird.
Und, ähm.
Und, genau.
Ich habe es, ich habe es doch genau richtig schon aufgeschrieben.
Ich habe mir hier aufgeschrieben,
versuchen die Essenz zu verstehen von dem, was gesagt wird.
Und wenn einer zwei Minuten
was Komplexes erzählt,
nicht zehn Minuten
über eine falsche Sache,
die er vielleicht gesagt hat,
ähm,
sich auslassen.
Ja, das, das trifft es auch,
es trifft es auch eigentlich ganz gut.
Schreiben wir,
das schreibe ich noch einmal anders her.
Versuchen die Essenz
des Gesagten
zu verstehen.
Zum Beispiel, jemand erzählt
zwei Minuten was Komplexes,
dann muss man nicht
zehn Minuten über
ein falsches
Wort, äh,
reden. So.
Ich glaube, das trifft es, das trifft es eigentlich ganz gut.
So, next, nächstes, nächstes Thema.
Ähm.
Ach ja, genau, habe ich sogar noch,
habe ich ja sogar noch ein Beispiel für.
Ich habe, ich habe sogar noch ein Beispiel für.
Habe ich mir aufgeschrieben.
Und zwar, ähm,
es, es ging da drum,
ich mache da mal einen Beispielsatz draus, ja.
Also, stellt euch vor,
stellt euch vor, jemand sagt,
man hat Schwierigkeiten, Tickets zu finden,
weil die Nummer
sich nicht am Projekt orientiert,
sondern immer lange Random-IDs generiert.
Also, man kann sich die Tickets nicht merken, weil
das nur lange Random-IDs sind und nicht das Projekt.
Also, man kann sich die Tickets nicht merken, weil das nur lange Random-IDs sind und nicht das Projekt.
Ich finde, relativ klare Aussage, oder?
Aber, man kann natürlich 10 Minuten darüber diskutieren,
dass es ja keine Tickets, sondern Service-Requests sind.
Versteht ihr, was ich meine?
Wenn man sich auf die Essenz dieser Aussage konzentrieren würde,
ist es scheißegal, ob es Tickets oder Service-Requests sind.
Es geht darum, dass sich derjenige,
egal ob Tickets oder Service-Requests,
sie sich nicht merken kann, weil kein Projekt drinsteht.
Versteht ihr, was ich meine?
Also, das ist halt auch so ein Ding.
Das schreibe ich mir genau als Beispiel rein.
Das habe ich mir auch gemeint.
Ja, das sind auch so Aussagen, die in deinem Zweifelsfall kommen können.
Okay, ne passt, das ist richtig.
So, das nächste ist,
ich glaube, da spreche ich nicht an,
dass wir allgemein super unflexibel sind,
irgendwas zu machen.
Wir könnten noch TMAX auf alle unsere Server installieren.
Das war ein halber Weltuntergang teilweise schon wieder.
Weil man da an so vielen Stellen ja was machen muss.
Und da hat man unnötige Binaries auf dem System und sowas.
Alter, es geht um TMAX.
Das ist 40 Kilobyte groß oder so
und ist enorm praktisch, wenn es halt einfach drauf ist.
Aber das ist so ein Ding,
das hat mich nur persönlich aufgeregt.
Das ist eigentlich wurscht.
Ich kann es verstehen, dass man keinen Bock hat,
einen großen Aufriss zu machen.
Was das ist?
Ich kann es dir zeigen.
Wir gucken übrigens mal, wie groß das ist.
Oh shit!
Alter, ist das etwa?
Ist das etwa 1 MB groß?
Bloated as fuck, man!
1,1 MB!
Ja, das geht nicht.
Das ist unmöglich.
Das können wir nicht machen.
Not possible.
Da ist die SSD voll.
Okay, next.
Nächstes Thema. Das lassen wir weg.
Das nächste, hatte ich schon
halb AFK während Meetings.
So, das elfte,
nicht elfte, das sechste Punkt ist
AskIquarium, beste.
Also,
ähm, nächster Punkt ist,
wie gesagt, also seit
mein Chef am Start ist,
habe ich mit ihm, glaube ich, dreimal gesprochen.
Und
ich fände es nice,
wenn man den mal ein bisschen
irgendwie öfters zu fassen bekommt.
Ja.
Also,
immer Chef oft
selten, selten greifbar.
Gibt
immer mal kleine
Orgasachen zu besprechen
und so weiter.
Aber meistens nicht wirklich.
Ja.
Das ist halt echt was,
ich weiß nicht, was sie den ganzen
Tag machen, die Führungskräfte da, aber
ich meine, da gibt sich sichtlich
Mühe,
indem da auch teilweise, wenn er schon weg ist,
in Teams antwortet und sowas.
Aber das ist ja auch für ihn kacke.
Ja.
Jaja, ne kannst du vergessen.
Die sind oftmals
ganze Wochen
weg auf irgendwelchen
Führungskräftemaßnahmen und sowas.
Ne, haben wir nicht.
Das fände ich,
das fände ich echt ganz gut.
Das fände ich echt
ganz gut.
Sagen wir mal, irgendwie, ja.
Einmal Woche,
mindestens einmal im Monat,
Chefs, irgendwie.
Damit man sich einfach mal auslassen
kann. Das würde echt was bringen.
Da kann man sich auch mal, wenn es schlecht läuft,
irgendwie ein Projekt drüber auskotzen, ob der
vielleicht noch eine Idee hat. Oder wenn
man irgendwas, was weiß ich,
irgendwie
sonst was nicht
passt, oder.
Es ist einfach besser.
Man kann regelmäßig mal
recht ungezwungen mit seinem Chef schwätzen,
anstatt, dass er dich
aus dem Feierabend im Bus
noch im Zug mal anrufen muss, oder so.
Oder aus dem Auto. Das ist
doof. Also,
das würde echt was bringen.
Ja, das wäre nice.
So, siebtens. Ich glaube, wir haben gar nicht mehr.
Das war's. Ja.
Das war's.
Chat gibt. Fertig.
Eine Stunde haben wir gebraucht.
Das ist ja noch nicht mal eine Seite.
Ich glaube, das...
Ich muss mir gerade noch mal kurz meine andere Sache durchlesen.
Das brauchen wir nicht.
Okay.
Das kann weg.
Das kann auch weg. Okay. Nice.
Excellent.
Okay. Wie kommst du da jetzt
gerade drauf?
Bislang gibt es eine Setup-Tour.
Es gibt auf YouTube ein Video von meinem Serverraum.
Und...
Das war's.
Ich glaube, es gibt...
Habe ich euch mal das Raspberry Pi
Setup im Keller gezeigt?
Nee, ich glaube, habe ich noch gar nicht gemacht.
Es gibt ein aktuelles Video aus
meinem Serverraum. Aber ansonsten
gibt es da nicht...
Hier gibt es auch nicht viel ans Setup zu sehen.
Ach ja. Und ein Video über meinen neuen PC
gibt es auch.
Also, da muss ich sagen,
da bin ich mittlerweile schmerzlos,
was das angeht.
Ich habe mir vorgenommen, damals,
als ich noch beim Provider meine Ausbildung,
also dort, wo ich meine Ausbildung gemacht habe
und da weg bin, da habe ich oftmals
Sachen, die mich genervt haben,
habe ich mich nicht getraut,
was dazu zu sagen. Oder ich dachte mir, ey,
wenn man das jetzt
anspricht, dann hat man da nur
Probleme draus und so.
Und da habe ich mir vorgenommen, ey,
wenn es Dinger gibt,
die mir auf den Keks
gehen, die aber,
sagen wir mal so, jetzt nicht
so
global-galaktisch sind,
wo ich dann sagen würde, ey,
das hat keinen Sinn,
dass ich einfach was zu sage.
Natürlich
nur, wenn es nicht ganz zu nervig wird.
Also, wenn ich,
ich wäge immer noch ab,
dazwischen, macht es Sinn, was zu sagen,
weil wenn du daraus dann selbst
nur Arbeit hast und das nichts bringt,
dann kann man es auch gleich sein lassen.
Aber beispielsweise jetzt auf dem Teambuilding
irgendwie nicht ansprechen, dass wir teilweise
uns zu sehr sidetracken lassen
oder
zu sehr
über kleine Sachen zu diskutieren,
selbst wenn es
manchen Leuten nicht gefällt,
da müssen sie halt durch.
Ja, das verstehe ich, das finde ich auch
nicht gut.
Definiere mal bitte Sidetracking.
Hast du schon mal einen Stream von mir Sonntagmorgens gesehen?
Okay, anscheinend nicht.
Also, Sidetracking
ist, ich versuche das jetzt mal irgendwie
für mich
in Worte zu fassen ist,
wenn man eine Sache machen will
oder sich um eine Sache, genau, der Stream ist eigentlich,
der Inbegriff von Sidetracking bei mir Sonntags,
wenn man, also ein bisschen off-topic
quasi, ja,
also wenn man zum Beispiel sagt,
ich gucke mir jetzt dieses Video an
und ich fange
10 Sekunden an zu gucken und sage,
ach, da fällt mir ja auch noch was
dazu ein und dann redet man
15 Minuten über den ersten Satz
in dem Video. Man kommt halt so
von einem Thema zum anderen
und kümmert
sich nie um die eigentliche Sache, um die
es gehen sollte. Ja.
Das stimmt.
Keck, geh.
Aber, T++ ist auch prinzipiell
was, wo ich mich, wo ich mich gerne drüber
auslasse. Topic?
Wir sind fertig. Ich habe eine Liste
erstellt. Abschweifen.
Genau, Abschweifen ist eine
sehr gute Übersetzung für Sidetracking.
Da versteht man auch was Gemeines. Ich habe morgen
und übermorgen einen Teambuilding Workshop
und hatte mir die letzten Wochen über ein paar Sachen
aufgeschrieben,
wo ich denke, dass man die verbessern kann.
Wo man zumindest
drüber reden, drüber reden könnte.
Und jetzt habe ich versucht, daraus mal
eine Liste zu erstellen, die man
versteht. Oh, Sixth Health.
Ja, Event. Aber natürlich
bezahltes Event. Ich glaube nicht, dass
ich da einfach so just for fun hingehe.
Aber wenn man das schon hat,
dann kann man ja, also, ich habe
keine Ahnung, wie dieses Event wird.
Vielleicht ist
es ja auch so ein, so ein,
ja, wie ich euch letztens erzählt habe, wo wir
gegen die Wand gespuckt haben im Teambuilding. Vielleicht
ist es auch sowas, wo so die ganze Zeit
irgendwelche blöden Teambuilding-Spielchen gemacht
werden. Da werde ich mich dann zurückhalten
und nur das Nötigste mitmachen.
Was, du wirst nicht glauben, hatte gestern
eine Anfrage von einem Kunden, der mir
vorgegeben hat, was ich ihm anbieten soll
und auch, wie ich es konfigurieren soll.
Naja,
also,
wenn der Kunde genaue Vorstellungen hat,
ist doch umso besser für dich, oder?
Da weißt du, dann ist, umso
weniger offene Fragen, umso besser.
Da weißt du wenigstens, was der will.
Und du baust nicht was hin und am Ende sagt er, ach nee,
ich wollte doch was ganz anderes.
Wenn es natürlich schon in dem Umfang ist,
dass man sich fragen muss,
ey, warum macht er es dann nicht selber, wenn er alles im Detail
schon so genau weiß? Ja, keine Ahnung.
Vielleicht, weil er keinen hat, der es kann.
Ja, wo ist das Problem?
Ey, es ist doch mal zur Abwechslung gut,
wenn die eine genaue Vorstellung
haben von dem, was sie haben wollen.
Normalerweise ist
das so, ist das eher so wie auf diesem Bild
mit der Schaukel.
Das kennt ihr doch alle. Warte mal, wie ist das denn hier?
Projektmanagement
Schaukel
Schaukel, das Bild.
Hier, das da.
Normalerweise ist es doch so.
Ja.
How the customer explain it.
How the project leader understood it.
How the analyst designed it.
Im Endeffekt, what the customer
really need. Normalerweise ist es doch so.
Und wenn das da
und das da möglichst nah
beieinander liegen, ist doch umso besser, oder?
Ja.
Aber anscheinend wusste er es in dem Fall doch.
Ich meine,
vielleicht kannst du es ja ein bisschen näher erzählen.
Also ich meine, in dem Fall wissen wir es nicht, aber
ich finde es immer prinzipiell gut, wenn die Leute,
die was haben wollen,
schon etwas
konkretere Vorstellungen haben, als einfach
nur mach mal.
Er sagt, er will genau 6 Apps,
ach, Access Points, er will 6 Access Points
und die sollen genau da und da platziert werden.
Dann pflege ich das und sehe, dass es von vorne
und hinten nicht geht.
Ja gut.
Das verstehe ich.
Ich denke, okay, das ist natürlich was anderes,
wenn er darauf besteht,
dass du was technisch
unsinniges machst.
Wenn ich das mal richtig zusammenfasse.
Habe ich das richtig zusammengefasst?
Da bleibt dir
im Endeffekt nichts übrig, wie zu sagen,
ey, weißt du was, ich baue hier nichts halbfertiges,
von dem ich eh weiß, dass es nicht geht.
Oder aber, du lässt dir das halt exakt
schriftlich so
in den Vertrag reinschreiben, dass das so ist.
Du kannst dich ja sogar darauf hinweisen,
dass du denkst, dass das nicht
die optimale Lösung ist für ihn.
Aber wenn er das so haben will,
ich meine, man muss sehen,
wie man, wo man bleibt.
Man kann niemanden davon abhalten,
Scheiße zu kaufen.
Aber ich verstehe es schon, man möchte ja,
das kann ich schon nachvollziehen,
man möchte ja schon technisch
gut funktionierende und saubere Lösungen
hinbauen, anstatt
irgendwas hingewurschteltes.
Er gibt mir auch die,
dann hat er gelitten.
Also entweder willst du es zu dem Preis machen oder nicht,
wahrscheinlich nicht, dann hat er halt Pech.
Dann hat er gelitten.
Also wenn er anfängt so nach dem Motto,
ich will exakt das und das, es darf aber nicht mehr
als das kosten und du denkst dir,
Alter, dafür kann ich noch nicht mal
kann ich noch nicht mal irgendwie
bin ich noch nicht mal aufgestanden und hingefahren,
so, dann
dann nicht, ja.
Das hier beschreibt es ganz gut.
Ja.
Genau so ist es im Endeffekt.
Für den Preis kriegt
ja nicht mal ich den bei Amazon.
Geschweige denn
von Einbau, Aufbau
ähm
und allem drum herum.
Ja, dann hat er halt Pech.
Dann hat er halt gelitten.
Dann gibt es halt nichts.
Also, wir haben das ja heute wunderbar hingekriegt.
Haben wir noch irgendein Video,
was wir uns angucken können, so jetzt
so die letzten 45 Minuten.
Achso, ich sollte mir das hier
erstmal rüber
kopieren, dass ich das dann nachher ausdrucken kann.
Fireship.
Ja, können wir tatsächlich machen.
Düdüdüdüdüdüdü.
Fireship
können wir tatsächlich gucken.
Aber haben wir noch irgendwas anderes?
Ach, was der Lindner macht, interessiert mich jetzt
ehrlich gesagt überhaupt nicht.
Desktop Environment Tierlist.
Oh ne, nicht nochmal, nicht nochmal.
E3 dabei.
Ich mein, E3 ist kein Desktop Environment, aber
seriously.
E3 beste.
Die schreckliche NFT Hölle des
Black & White Erfinders. Ach
hat, hat, hat
Peter mal wieder
ein neues Scam Game rausgehauen.
So nach den letzten irgendwie
gefühlten 5 Dingern,
die er rausgebracht hat und nie
weiterentwickelt hat.
Haben wir sonst noch?
Äh, what?
OKS.
Das haben wir doch schon geguckt.
Das haben wir auch schon geguckt.
Das haben wir nicht geguckt.
So, YouTube, was gibt's hier so als Empfehlung?
Der große Vertrauensbruch.
Das halten die Deutschen
von ihrer Regierung.
Okay, aktuell glaube ich halten sehr viele
nichts davon.
Ich halte eigentlich schon
die ganzen letzten Jahre
und inklusive jetzt
nichts davon.
Aber gut.
Man hat ja wenig Einfluss drauf,
außer ab und zu mal wählen zu gehen.
The most epic GitHub Pull Request.
Okay, Fireship.
Was hat Fireship am Start?
Hier.
Oh ne, auf das OpenAI
Drama habe ich keinen Bock.
YouTube Adblock
Wars. Okay, das können wir mal gucken.
Fireship ist immer nice.
Kannst du den Anfang von dem 37
Minuten Video schauen?
Das da?
Hard Drives.
Um was geht's da überhaupt?
Nehmen wir das mal zu.
Ja, ich habe tatsächlich in Hessen auch wieder
die FDP gewählt.
Der Markt regelt das.
Komm, wir gucken jetzt erstmal
Fireship. Und danach gucken
wir vielleicht, das andere weiß ich nicht.
Irgendwie spricht mich das nicht so an.
Das sieht ein bisschen nach Cocker aus.
Also Fireship,
let's go.
Hat lange nichts hochgeladen.
You may not realize it, but we're in the middle
of a high stakes war. Not in the Middle East,
but right here in your browser.
Hey, Cod 4 Gameplay.
... is a few precious seconds of your attention
while staring at this magic glowing
screen. It is November 24th, 2023
and you're watching The Code Report.
Back in June 2023,
a small group of YouTube users were surprised to get
this message, cutting them off for having an
Adblocker enabled, making them the first casualties
of YouTube's Adblocker blocker.
Because you're just a material girl living in
a material world, your attention is very valuable.
It only takes a few seconds for a good advertisement
to inject some information into your
hippocampus, where it can then be transferred to the
frontal lobe to manipulate your impulse control
to get you to buy something you don't need.
By the way guys, Black Friday, Cyber Monday
sale, Fireship Pro, 40%.
Ach, heut ist ja Cyber Monday, ja.
Habt ihr irgendwas gekauft jetzt bei dieser ganzen
Black Friday, Cyber Monday Geschichte?
Ich hab was gekauft, aber nicht explizit
im Black Friday, sondern einfach weil ich's gebraucht
hab. Ich hab mir noch
zwei Paare
so neongelbe Socken
zum Rennen gekauft.
Das ist eine gute Frage, da kann ich was zu sagen.
Chat, ich lass mich kurz sidetracken,
alles klar?
Sie schaben mit .NET, Selfcontained oder
Golang für Cross-Platform-CLI.
Ich will mir ein kleines Pomodoro bauen.
Also unabhängig davon, was du dir bauen willst,
ist es wahrscheinlich ein
Command Line Tool.
Steht ja auch da.
Und dazu kannst du beides
verwenden. Was dir lieber ist,
ich persönlich mag .NET lieber,
Go ist aber auch super.
Was in Go halt total easy
ist, ist tatsächlich
Cross-Platform und möglichst
lang rückwärtskompatibel, aber
mit .NET 8 ist das in .NET
selbst auch deutlich besser geworden.
Und ich würde gar nicht .NET
Selfcontained nehmen, sondern ich würde
.NET Ahead of Time
kompiliert nehmen.
Und dann kompilierst du das Ganze in
einem Docker-Container
zum Beispiel mit
Ubuntu 16.04
und dann bekommst du
ein Selfcontained Native Binary
raus, was lauffähig
ist auf allen Linux-Distributionen der letzten
10 Jahre. Ja gut,
ja doch, fast.
Oder 14.04 kann man
glaube ich sogar noch nehmen.
Also Go kann das out of the box,
weil Go halt keinerlei
Systemabhängigkeiten bundelt
oder voraussetzt.
C-Sharp hat auch
mit Ahead of Time Compilation
so gut wie keine
Systemvoraussetzungen, allerdings
haben die aus irgendwelchen Gründen
die aktuellen libc
Versionen
als Requirement
drinne von dem System, wo man es drauf
kompiliert hat. Das heißt, wenn du es in einem
ollen Docker-Container kompilierst,
hast du auch ein Binary, was rückwirkend
lauffähig ist auf allen
Linux der letzten 10 Jahre.
Also im Prinzip, du kannst es mit beidem
gut machen, wenn es Command-Line-Self-Contained
Cross-Platform-Applications
sein sollen. Und wenn du
Minus-Minus-Self-Contained nimmst, kannst du das ganze
auch sein lassen, weil dann
benutzt er das
offizielle
ja, die offizielle .NET Runtime
und die wurde glaube ich gebaut
auf nem, oder mit
mit Libraries von Ubuntu 14.04
oder sowas. Ist also auch
lange rückwirkend. Windows, Ubuntu
bzw. Docker Desktop. Achso, wenn du unter
Windows bist, vergiss es. Dann nimm lieber
Go.
Wenn du unter Windows entwickelst und
Cross-Platform für Linux und Windows machen willst,
keine Ahnung.
Docker und Windows ist
mir einfach sehr sus.
Äh, dann nimm lieber
Docker. Äh, dann nimm lieber
dann nimm lieber Go.
Wenn du easy
Cross-Platform und rückwirkend kompatible
Binaries brauchst, dann
nimm Go.
Wenn du kein ordentlich funktionierendes
Docker hast und unter Windows bist, dann
nimm lieber Go.
Okay, Fireship weitergucken.
Leicht zeitgetrackt.
...learn to code and get a free t-shirt.
Buy it now before the impulse fades from your prefrontal
cortex. That's an example of an honest
advertisement that you should definitely take advantage
of. But most companies need to pay someone else
to shill for them. In 2022,
Alphabet the company generated 280
billion dollars in revenue. That's a lot
...ist ja fast nix.
...a lot of money, but 224 billion
of that is from advertisements.
...what's even more crazy. Das ist heftig, oder?
Das ist richtig heftig.
Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht, dass
bei Google der
Anteil von
Cloud
auch höher ist mittlerweile.
Bei Microsoft ist ja quasi
Cloud-Services die Hälfte von dem, was sie verdienen.
...of that 224,
only 29 billion comes from...
Stimmt, was macht... Moment, Moment,
lass mich mal kurz gucken. Was macht mein ETF
eigentlich? Stonks.
Sekunde, was macht mein ETF?
Lass mich mal kurz checken.
Okay.
Stonks sind wieder hochgegangen.
Nice. Stonks sind wieder ein bisschen
gestiegen die letzte Woche.
Ja.
Also, wisst ihr,
Adblocker sind
aufgewachsen
zu
...
Ja, also, wisst ihr,
Adblocker sind aufgewachsen,
ursprünglich, genau aus
einem ähnlichen Grund.
Webseiten waren eigentlich ganz gut zu benutzen.
Alles gut. So. Dann gab's
Werbung. Das war auch noch okay.
Dann gab's ein bisschen mehr Werbung. Das war auch noch okay.
So, und irgendwann gab es
mega viel Werbung. Das hat schon abgefuckt.
Dann haben schon viele angefangen.
Und dann gab es noch Werbung,
die schädlich für dich war.
Also, von Flash-Werbung wurde dir
von Flash- und Java-Applet-Werbung,
was es früher nicht alles für ein Shit gab,
wurde dir im Zweifelsfall noch Viren aufgewachsen.
Auf deinem Rechner einfangen konntest,
oder einfach nur dein Browser gefreestest,
oder was auch immer. Und spätestens da haben die Leute gesagt,
Nope.
Adblocker.
Da war's überschritten.
...
AdGuard, Ghostery, uBlock Origin, AdBlocker Ultimate
or use privacy-focused browsers like Brave,
YouTube is going to go out of business
and take all of its creators with it.
That's the argument anyway.
And YouTube has been cracking down.
Recently it's been promoting its own AdBlocker,
YouTube Premium,
and it shares revenue from that product
with YouTube creators.
Das Ding ist halt,
die meisten Creator
dürften einen Großteil ihrer Einnahmen
nicht von YouTube Werbung
und YouTube AdSense bekommen.
Von Werbung auf YouTube in ihren Videos
definitiv, von Sponsorings,
von allem auf jeden Fall.
Das gefällt YouTube halt nicht so sehr,
dass sie auf ihrer Plattform am Start sind
und sie selbst davon
nicht so viel abbekommen,
wie sie könnten.
Ich bin mir auch gar nicht sicher,
ob es Statistiken dazu gibt,
wie es so mit Einnahmen und Ausgaben
bei YouTube aussieht.
Also ich weiß, dass YouTube lange Zeit
keine Kohle abgeworfen hat.
Mittlerweile ja anscheinend schon.
Aber ich bin mal gespannt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass YouTube
das auf Dauer gewinnen kann.
Man könnte jetzt auch sagen,
hey, die AdBlocker können nicht auf Dauer gewinnen,
weil YouTube hat ja viel einfachere Möglichkeiten,
was zu ändern.
Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass das YouTube nicht auf Dauer gewinnen kann.
Weil entweder
es normale User irgendwann so krass abfuckt,
alles,
und sie abhauen
und sich halt nicht mehr geben
und lieber Twitch gucken,
oder so.
Die müssen halt,
die versuchen halt,
die Balance zu finden.
Gerade.
Zwischen wie sehr können wir die Leute gängeln
und wie machen sie es gerade noch mit,
dass wir noch Maximum an Kohle kriegen.
Das ist der Test gerade.
In Full Disclosure,
I've been an affiliate for YouTube Premium
in a past video,
and I currently use it myself.
But there is a significant number of people out there
who you couldn't pay to pay for the service.
Ich habe auch YouTube Premium.
No matter how much advertising
you try to inject into their encephalons.
Facebook also waged war against AdBlockern,
back in 2016,
but largely failed,
although Netflix recently cracked down on account sharing,
which to them is considered theft,
and their stonks have been way up ever since.
And the thing is,
YouTube could just ignore this issue
and chalk it up to the cost of doing business on the Internet,
but instead they woke up and chose violence.
If you have an AdBlocker enabled,
you may get this warning,
that video playback will be disabled
if you don't disable your AdBlocker.
In addition,
the overall experience for AdBlock users
will likely get worse in the future.
Like recently,
a small group of users were noticing a 5-second delay
before a video started playing,
which is apparently part of YouTube's efforts
to detect AdBlockers.
Now, a bigger part of this war, though,
comes down to Chrome Extensions.
Bald braucht man den AdBlocker,
AdBlock-Erkennungs-Entfernungs-AdBlocker.
Also sowas gibt's ja schon.
To build a Chrome Extension,
you have to have a manifest.json file.
This file defines what the extension is allowed to do.
Da hatte ich's doch letztens von,
wo man wieder gesehen hat,
dass es doch nicht so gut ist,
wenn die Macht alles bei einer Firma liegt, ja?
Plattformbetreiber und Browseranbieter,
in einem.
Da kannst du halt sowas machen wie,
Moment, alle, die unseren Browser verwenden,
die können halt einfach keinen AdBlock mehr benutzen.
Ja, ja, sagt alles vorbei, ja, Pech gehabt.
Die rudern dann nur immer wieder zurück,
weil der Aufschrei noch groß genug ist.
Die probieren das immer wieder,
bis der Aufschrei nicht mal groß genug ist.
Glücklicher, also wir können echt froh sein,
dass es Firefox gibt.
Da sieht man, dass es echt wichtig ist,
bei solcher essentiellen Software
wie Webbrowser Alternativen zu haben.
... on the user's behalf.
... access network request to block ads.
If we look at the manifest for uBlock,
you'll first notice that it's using manifest version 2.
Then if we go down to permissions,
you'll notice it's using web request
and web request blocking.
These APIs made it easy for an extension
to intercept a network request
and then modify it so it can't display the ad it wants to.
Now the thing is, manifest version 2
is being deprecated in favor of version 3,
which replaces the web request API
with the declarative net request API,
which is far more limited
when it comes to dynamically filtering content.
What's kind of funny,
is that Chrome actually might need ad blockers,
because as recently as last Christmas,
the FBI was recommending people install them
to protect against malicious advertisements
hosting ransomware.
Ultimately, I do think it's possible
that YouTube could eradicate ad blockers altogether.
But currently, it's a lot like when Barbara Streisand
tried to suppress a photo of her house
that almost nobody knew about,
resulting in the opposite intended effect,
making the photo extremely famous.
We're currently seeing the Streisand effect
with ad blockers,
where more and more people are learning about them
and using them,
despite the fact that they violate the terms of service.
It's also making the ad blockers
become more sophisticated.
It's only a matter of time
before someone invents an ad blocker blocker blocker
that can block this ad blocker.
Das gibt es schon!
Das gibt es ja schon!
Blocker blocker.
Forcing YouTube to then invent its own
ad blocker blocker blocker blocker.
At which point, this joke becomes too repetitive.
This has been the Code Report.
Was zum Teufel bin ich da auf der rechten Seite sehend?
And I will see you in the next one.
Das hat Scooby jung und chancenlos.
Warum?
Okay, 44 Minuten kann ich mir jetzt nicht angucken.
Aber man muss sagen,
FireShip macht immer nice Videos.
Oh, guck mal!
Mein eigenes Video wird mir empfohlen.
View Time.
Pogu.
Tanzverbot ist...
Was, ernsthaft?
Ich meine, ich verfolge Tanzverbot jetzt
nicht aktiv,
aber so die eine oder andere sagt,
der hat auf mich jetzt nie gewirkt,
als hat er einen super krassen Lebensstil gehabt,
der Millionen verschlingt.
Ich meine, genug Kohle machen sollte er doch eigentlich, oder nicht?
Sind die auf einmal alle pleite?
Was ist da los?
Was ist der Inzi-Modus bei ApoRed?
Gibt es da Neuigkeiten zu?
Ich verfolge das ja nicht so richtig.
Steuerschulden.
Ja, da hast du gelitten.
Beim Finanzamt kommst du nicht vorbei.
Das ist halt immer...
Das siehst du schon, auch als Normalsterblicher,
wenn du Post vom Finanzamt kriegst.
Das besteht aus einer halben Seite
mit Dingern, die du machen sollst
und dann sieben Seiten Rechtsbelehrung,
was passiert, wenn du es nicht machst.
Ich schaue mir den Anfang vom Video an.
Okay, weil...
Ico, weil du es bist.
Ich schaue mir jetzt den Anfang von deinem Video an,
was du geschickt hast.
Wie lang?
Wann ist der Anfang vorbei?
Bei 36 Minuten?
Erste Minute, okay?
Das ist mir zu hell.
Was sind wir sehend?
Das Video, was Ico geschickt hat,
ich weiß auch noch nicht so genau.
Aber leider,
wenn du sie hoch genug schiebst,
musst du sie schnell genug schießen,
damit sie über die Ausgabe-Velocity
von 11.000 Kilometern pro Sekunde überstehen.
Und dann, anstatt zurück zu kommen,
gehen sie einfach in den Raum.
Aber du weißt, wir sind nicht unabhängig
von diesen Dingen.
Wir könnten sie auch tangent zur Erde schießen,
ohne die Ausgabe-Velocity.
Und das wird eine Orbit erzeugen,
wo sie um die Erde gehen
und zurückkommen und in unsere andere Hand landen.
Das ist sehr einfach für das Juggeln.
Hier ist eine Computer-Simulation davon.
Wir können natürlich keine Luftresistenz verhindern,
weil Chainsaws die Luft wie Butter ausbrechen.
Wir bekommen eine schöne elliptische Orbit.
Und natürlich können wir viele Chainsaws
in diese Orbit packen.
Was hältst du von Blaulicht-Filterbrillen?
Ich habe selbst mal eine benutzt,
eine Zeit lang, eine Gunner Optics-Brille,
die das Ganze so gelblich gemacht hat,
aber nutze ich nicht mehr.
Aber gleichzeitig
habe ich die Möglichkeit,
sie zu fangen.
Mal sehen, ob ich sie fangen kann.
Oh, na gut, ziemlich nah.
Was sind wir hier sehend, Leute?
Jetzt haben wir diese Chainsaws,
die bei 11.000 km pro Sekunde schießen.
Wir fangen sie an
und fangen sie zurück in die Orbit.
Die Chainsaws können effizient
in diesem schönen Arrangement gepackt werden.
Was uns also wirklich limitieren wird,
ist das Volumen der Chainsaws,
die wir in diese ansteckende Umgebung
für das Juggeln befinden können.
In diesem Volumen werden wir sehen...
Hi-I-Q-Zeug! Bis jetzt ist es sehr gut.
... ungefähr 55.390 Chainsaws pro Sekunde.
Und da eine Orbit 335,6 Stunden dauert,
dauert es so lange, bis wir eine Chainsaw
zum zweiten Mal sehen.
So werden wir gleichzeitig
1,215 x 10¹⁰ Chainsaws vergrößern.
Das ist eine Konfiguration,
die Terrawield genannt wird.
Nun, ich habe keine Chainsaws.
Ich lebe in einer Stadt,
wo ich zwei Bäume habe,
und wenn ich sie abschneide, bin ich fertig.
Also werden es keine Chainsaws sein.
Aber wir könnten versuchen,
mit etwas zu juggeln,
das noch gefährlicher ist.
Daten.
War das jetzt die Überleitung
zum eigentlichen Thema?
Ja, das war die Überleitung zum eigentlichen Thema.
Wir haben im Video
eine Überleitung von
50 Millisekunden
für die Geschwindigkeit,
die die Radio-Wave
um die Erde
umsetzen kann.
Das hat mir YouTube übrigens nicht geglaubt.
Ich habe das auch mal
in einem Video erzählt.
Das war ein Beispiel für,
wenn du auf einem China-Server spielst
und was du für einen Mindest-Ping hast,
wenn du mit Lichtgeschwindigkeit rechnest.
Da habe ich den Leuten vorgerechnet,
dass du quasi,
ich glaube, es waren über den Daumen gepeilt,
50 Millisekunden oder so,
wenn du auf dem Server in China spielst.
Und da haben die Leute
in den Kommentaren gesagt,
nein, nein, Max, das stimmt nicht.
Lichtgeschwindigkeit ist viel.
Ich habe es in dem fucking Video
vorgerechnet, Mann.
Und die Leute haben immer noch gesagt,
das stimmt nicht.
Das stimmt nicht.
Okay, ich bin immerhin,
das muss ich sagen,
das ist ganz selten,
dass die Leute Ping mal korrekt bezeichnen.
ICMP-Echo-Request, ICMP-Echo-Reply.
And that message basically consists of a packet
that says what your source IP address is
and where you're sending it,
the destination IP.
And there's a payload,
some freeform data,
which gets returned as is.
So I send one of these packets to Australia
with my return address on it
and some data that I want to
quote unquote store.
Then I can discard that data
and when it comes back,
I can read it.
And I could do this to a bunch of hosts
around the Internet
and in doing so store a significant,
let's see,
amount of data in the Internet.
So let's do that.
And not just that.
Ich glaube, ich weiß, worauf er raus will.
Er will Daten quasi in seinem Ping verstecken
und er rechnet jetzt wahrscheinlich aus,
wie viel Pings er losschicken muss,
dass er seine Daten quasi in transit
safen kann.
Irgendwie was in der Richtung
kommt jetzt wahrscheinlich.
This is the true story of hard drives
we didn't want or need.
It's called Harder Drive.
Harder Drive.
By the way, this ICMP echo thing
is also known as a ping.
So I put together some code
to send out a lot of pings.
Mein Auge ist zu hell.
Für solche Fälle
brauche ich irgendwie
ein halbtransparentes schwarzes Fenster,
was ich drüber machen kann.
I figured,
why not ping the whole Internet?
So I did.
By Internet here I mean
the IPv4 address space,
which are addresses that you know and love,
like a.b.c.d.
Each of which can go from 0 to 255.
Those are 8 bits.
So together we have 32 bits
or 4.2 billion addresses.
I don't care about IPv6.
There's way too many addresses
and most of them aren't used.
Plus, like,
call me when you're at least version 7.
Am I right?
IPv4 is great
and 4.2 billion isn't that big of a number anymore.
With my home Internet,
which is advertised as 1 gigabit per second,
I should be able to finish in about 20 minutes.
Or, you know, a couple hours.
Or most a week.
Well, it turns out that sending this many pings
was hell on my home network.
And not only does it end up
dropping a lot of the pings,
so it's useless,
it renders the whole network
completely unusable,
which is definitely a no-no
for the work-from-home lifestyle.
And I was really only able to push this
to about 1,000 pings per second,
which is nothing.
It could be that my ISP is throttling me
or there's NAT tables which aren't big enough
to handle this many different addresses
or DDoS protection.
Or I'm just bad at this.
Who knows?
In any case, I ended up renting some time
on some servers and some clusters
so that I could finish the job.
Because the best excuse is that
you just freaking did it.
So I finished it up.
And now we can look...
So ganz check ich immer noch nicht so genau,
worauf er raus will,
weil selbst wenn du deine Daten
quasi permanent im Internet hast,
weil du sie permanent immer
quasi in pings rumschicken...
Du brauchst die Daten ja weiterhin,
dass du deine pings ab und zu
refreshen kannst.
Oder baut er jetzt irgendwie so eine Art
Mesh-Network,
dass die dann irgendwie...
Keine Ahnung.
Okay.
Das ganze Internet.
So here is the Internet.
Let me zoom in a little bit.
Actually, let me zoom in a lot.
Here we have every IP address on the Internet.
You can see them at the bottom left.
And the dot will be white
if it responded to my ping
and black if not.
Okay.
And here I've arranged the IP addresses
using a Hilbert curve,
which is a sort of fractal space-filling curve,
it looks like this.
Ah, na klar.
Which is a standard way to do this.
Obvious.
This is not a video about the Hilbert curve.
It's not even a video
about pinging the Internet.
There's some somewhat interesting parts here.
So this white block here
always responded to my pings.
That's because it's the loopback address 127.star,
which is basically my local computer.
So it always responds to that.
Up here are a bunch of reserved
or multicast addresses.
So it makes sense
that none of those ever responded.
Throughout the rest,
we can see a lot of different characters.
So I'll just give you a bit of a tour,
depending on how this address space
has been allocated.
And each of these corresponds
to a different network,
which is broken into sub-networks.
This one has fairly fine-grained divisions.
This reminds me of a farmland allocation
in the United States.
Schon so ein bisschen.
That's that square.
Over here we see a network
that is very likely to respond to your ping,
although there are some blackout regions.
This area has all sorts of patterns.
Ja, okay.
Das müssen wir uns jetzt nicht im Detail angucken,
wie das ganze Internet auf pings antwortet, oder?
We've got some stuff
you could print on a tie.
We've got some mazes.
We've got some Tetris pieces.
Maybe even some letters here.
We've got a crossword puzzle.
By the way,
this way of mapping the Internet
is basically canonical.
And it wouldn't be that hard
to embed some kind of picture
or message in here.
Like, how cool would it be
to embed a little QR code in this, right?
Like, it would be a little bit cool.
Maybe a little embarrassing, too.
Anyway, that's the Internet.
Probably somewhere in here is your computer, too.
And now I yearn to build our first virtual hard drive
using what we've learned.
This turns out to be no big deal.
In UNIX, storage systems are abstracted
as quote-unquote block devices,
which are quote-unquote just files.
One way to make a block device
would be to implement a kernel module,
but then I'd be doing a lot of rebooting.
NBD kit, which stands for no big deal kit,
is a library for creating network block devices
in user space,
which you could use for serious purposes
or for silly purposes like today's.
In order to implement a device,
you just have to implement a function like read,
which takes some address and a length
and returns the data that's at that address
and write it, which does the opposite.
Once you make one of these virtual devices,
you can mount it on the system,
you can format it with some file system,
and then you can store files on it.
Now, the smallest block device
that I can make any use of is 51,200 bytes.
And to do that, I need to use the FAT12 file system,
which is from the DOS era,
used for like five and a quarter inch floppy drives.
So what we're gonna do is make a device
that has 100 512-byte blocks.
Each of those blocks is gonna be stored
by a number of outstanding pings.
And I'm gonna use multiple pings per block
for redundancy in case one of those pings doesn't...
Ja, aber der braucht die Daten doch trotzdem noch bei sich lokal,
dass er die Pings immer wieder losschicken kann.
Oder wie soll das funzen?
I don't wanna lose my data.
Now, despite the fact that I already pinged
the entire Internet,
I created the list of those hosts by hand.
And part of the reason for this is I wanted to make sure
I wasn't like hammering someone's cell phone
on a metered connection.
But also, I want hosts that are geographically diverse,
because I don't want correlated failures.
And I want them to be high reliability.
I want them to respond to my 512-byte pings
pretty much every time.
But I also want them to be slow.
And that's kind of a strange combination, right?
Usually you want it to be fast and reliable.
Aber die Antwort vom Ping enthält doch die Daten dann nicht mehr.
Wobei, kommt auf das Feld an, was du reinschreibst.
Kommt drauf an, wo du es reinschreibst wahrscheinlich.
Es gibt bestimmt ein paar Sachen,
die erhalten bleiben in der Antwort.
Okay, vielleicht, ja, dann würde es...
Dann würde es potenziell funktionieren.
Here I want it to be slow and reliable.
So, this wasn't so hard.
I searched for things like
most popular websites in Madagascar.
And I manually just checked them
until I found ones that had the desired qualities.
Now, you can check the technical report
for the implementation details.
Er will das langsam haben,
dass möglichst viele Pings unterwegs sind.
It is a little tricky to do this,
because since I'm not actually storing any of the data,
if someone wants to read from this drive,
I have to wait until I receive a ping back
before I can process their request.
And writes have a similar challenge.
The biggest problem here
is the aforementioned throttling
to about a thousand pings a second.
I barely got this...
Okay, dann, ich frag mich,
wo er das in seinem Ping-Package stort,
dass die Antwort da drauf
die Daten wieder enthält.
Weiß ich nicht, was man dafür missbrauchen kann
bei so einem ICMP-Paket.
...is working, but it would have been nice
if I could send a few million pings per second
instead of one thousand.
I also built a UI for this thing,
which we'll see in a second.
So now what I want to do is
stand up the drive
and I want to benchmark it
to see how well it performs.
In order to do that,
I need to figure out what data
I want to store in this drive.
So I decided a fitting file,
one that is a kind of improper hierarchy,
would be RFC 792,
a text file that describes
the Internet Control Message Protocol,
ICMP, echo, and echo reply
that we're using.
That thing is 30 kilobytes,
so it just barely fits on the drive.
So here it is running that benchmark.
The white blocks are healthy blocks.
Those are blocks where we have...
Der macht das bestimmt mit C++.
Da habe ich jetzt gleich noch
ein bisschen was zu lästern.
...have the full target number
of pings outstanding.
If a block isn't white,
that means we've lost a ping,
and then it's in danger of failing.
And that will happen all of the time.
The crossed out blocks have not yet been written,
so they don't have any data.
The red dot indicates a block
with an outstanding write,
so you'll see that move around
as the benchmark goes,
and a green block the same for reading.
At the bottom you can see
some of the hosts and statistics.
I keep track of the statistics on the host
so that I don't overload one host,
and if it becomes less reliable or too fast,
then I try to avoid using it.
After the benchmark finishes,
I guess there's a hiccup in the system or something,
and I actually do lose some data.
So a couple of these blocks die and don't come back.
That will happen.
This is not a reliable way of storing data.
But we can look at the file that I stored
and read that protocol description.
You'll see right here there's an area that was lost.
Das da im Hintergrund sieht schon ein bisschen nach C++ aus
wegen diesem komischen Redirector-Ding.
Und der Rest könnte auch C sein.
That's all zeros now.
But the benchmark did work completely,
so we can get some numbers.
But I don't just want to evaluate these drives by their speed.
Let's also consider the qualitative aspect.
Qualitatively, this is a pretty good harder drive.
It does solve a problem that we don't have.
Which is to pretend we have a fast network,
but no memory in which to store data.
It treats latency as a desirable quantity,
contrary to the usual preference.
And it was harder to make than I expected.
The cost is not too bad.
I have to have a computer,
but I always have to have a computer.
My home network costs about $80 a month
for one quote-unquote gigabit.
And this is about as much as I can store
before the thing fails.
So this ends up being about 0.15 cents.
Per byte per month.
Which is not too bad.
Longevity, however, is
Das ist ganz schön viel.
cents per byte per month.
Which is not too bad.
Das ist 0,1 Cent pro Byte.
Das ist, glaube ich,
weiß nicht, ob das wirklich,
das erscheint mir jetzt ziemlich viel.
10 Byte.
8 Byte.
Hast du dann einen Cent?
Das scheint mir nicht billig zu sein.
Longevity, however, is poor.
The benchmark succeeds with 100% accuracy,
like I mentioned.
But the data is lost readily
if you leave it running for a few minutes.
And since we store the data externally
using untrusted hosts,
they can just send back whatever data...
Also mich würde ja immer noch interessieren,
wie er das jetzt genau macht.
Weil ich dachte eigentlich immer,
dass du in einem Ping
du kannst ja zwar Zeug reinschreiben an Daten,
aber das, was zurückkommt,
muss ja nicht zwangsläufig
deine nicht wirklich pingrelevanten Sachen enthalten noch.
Oder doch?
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
...they want and corrupt the drive.
On the other hand,
since we don't store any data locally,
we could consider this non-volatile storage.
In the sense that if we completely lose power,
the data still exists,
as long as we can reboot in about 100 milliseconds.
To receive the pings as they arrive.
Which is kind of unlikely.
The speed is pretty slow.
I got about 14 kilobytes a second
reading and writing.
Gut, aber wir sollen's auch...
...which is basically the same operation.
...soll das auch viel schneller sein.
Power consumption for me is low,
but the internet itself actually uses a lot of power.
A typical undersea cable
is excited with power
on the order of tens of kilowatts.
And they have repeaters every 100 kilometers or so.
Which is a lot of power.
It's a lot of juice.
If I was the only one using this,
it would be very, very inefficient.
Fortunately, many people are using the internet.
And these pings are a tiny fraction of the bandwidth.
And if I assume that my internet bill
covers the marginal cost of the power
for the internet, which makes sense,
then it turns out to be about
5.8 microwatts.
In terms of harm to society,
the drive is definitely harmful
to my home network.
Whether you can consider that a positive
to society is left as an exercise to the reader.
At this scale,
it's a trivial impact
on the internet at large.
But if we were to do this to store
many terabytes of data,
or if everyone were doing this,
it would be pretty bad for the shared infrastructure.
We're kind of freeloading off the willingness
of other hosts to respond to our pings.
Und wo gibt es jetzt die Details?
Speaking of antisocial,
I'm sorry to remind you
about Vladimir Putin's
illegal invasion of Ukraine.
But this section concerns
a hard drive made from
Soviet blocks.
And when I say that,
of course I mean Tetris.
Tetris is an inventory management
survival horror game
from the Soviet Union
in 1984.
There are 19 principal characters,
which are these.
And like all living things,
they're made up of pixels or blocks.
So we can make a block device out of these.
The Tetris playfield is
10 squares wide and
Ist das jetzt schon das nächste Thema?
Und hat mit Ping nichts mehr zu tun?
Das ist schon das nächste Thema, oder?
Das ist jetzt irgendwie
Datenstorage in Tetris.
Scheint so.
Okay, das reicht mir.
Wir wissen, dass wir Sachen
pinkstoren können.
Alles klar.
Irgendwie war mir das indirekt
vorher schon klar.
Nur habe ich den Sinn davon...
Ich war mir aber nicht klar,
dass man da sowas draus...
Alter, schon wieder ein Update,
dass man da sowas draus bauen kann.
Wollen wir rebooten nochmal.
Massive Reboot.
So, Chat.
Wir haben jetzt noch 5 Minuten Zeit.
Gibt's noch irgendwas Wichtiges?
Was wir unbedingt
heute noch besprechen müssen?
Ja, ganz bestimmt.
Einer
mich irritiert mit der Anzeige
Desktop 1, Desktop 2.
Die ist neu. Die gibt's noch nicht so lange.
Was ist der Sinn des Lebens?
Möglichst viel das zu machen, worauf man Bock hat.
So.
Suspend.
Okay, Chat.
Wenn es sonst nichts mehr gibt,
dann sehen
wir uns morgen nicht. Morgen bin
ich auf meinem Teambuilding Workshop.
Sondern wir
sehen uns am
Mittwoch wahrscheinlich wieder.
Der Hentai Watcher.
Ist auch ein Name, Alter.
Ja, ganz bestimmt.
Ne. Also, wir sehen uns.
Bis denn. See you.
Beten.
Okay. Pray get time.
Oh, genug. Fertig. Bis denn.
See you.